قال نائب رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان
مالك عقار قال للجزيره ان باجنر قد تكون
لها علاقات استثماريه مع الدعم السريع
وكان عقار قد دعا روسيا للعب دور في انهاء
ازمه السودان كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق تاتي زياره
عقار الى موسكو وحديثه عن دوري فاجنر في
السودان وكيف
ستتعاطى روسيا مع هذه الدعوه وما الذي
يعنيه توسطها في الازمه السودانيه الان
وما هي حسابات اللاعبين الاقليمين
والدوليين في السودان
اكتب على عدم وجود اي عزله للحكومه
السودانيه للدوله السودانيه
والحكومه السودانيه ككل يبحثون عن وضاءات
جديده لخيارات
ومبادرات تختلف عن التي تم تجربها في
الفتره السابقه منذ اندلاع عن الحرب في 15
ابريل الماضي ملك عقار يبحث عنه في موسكو
هو التحدث الى الروس حول منع دعمه
للدعم السريع ما تريده
السودان هو منع مثل هذا الدعم وان لا تكون
في مركز قوي تعارض المصالح الدوليه
واختلاف المواقع المواقف تاتي بجديد عبر
روسيا من الواضح من روسيا تحاول ان
تستعيد
سيطره او المجال الذي كانت تسيطر فيه
مجموعه فاغنر وان تلعب دورا
اينما تفعله واشنطن والسعوديه
باتت يعني من يعني من الماضي تقريبا يعني
تجاوزت الخيارات السودانيه الاصيله التي
يبحث عنها السودانيون يعني الحكومه
السودانيه باتت يعني لا تفضلها ولم تجتهد
معها ولعدم حياديتها الطرفين المتحاربين
الان هي تساوي بين الدعم السريع وبين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه طرحت خيارات
تتصل بتفريغ العاصمه السودانيه من
المسلحين والقوات المسلحه
وكلائها مجموعه
استراتيجيه حقيقيه في افريقيا لتطوير
علاقات
تاخذ على حساب الغرب في مالي ونعرف انهم
يزيدون تاثيرهم في بلدان اخرى قوته ليست
موجوده في السودان لكنها موجوده في عدد من
الدول المجاوره وفي المناطق الحدوديه في
السودان قد تكون لها علاقه بقوات الدعم
السريع لكن على مستوى الاستثمارات فهناك
تقارير ان
مجموعه فاكتور توفر
للدعم السريع بعض الدعم عبر ليبيا وعبر
افريقيا الوسطى اعني صواريخ ارض جو
واسلحه
وربما وقود
ويمكن لموسكو ان تتوسط في كل ما يتعلق
بشؤون سودانيه
اولا هناك
سوابق تاريخيه لمشاركه موسكو الافريقيه
كينو ان تكون موسكو الحله الافضل
مقارنه بالقوى الغربيه لاتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه افتتدخل حتى في قضايا ايديولوجيه
فعاده ينظر الى الصين على انها قوه عظمى
ناشئه وربما استعماريه جديده
التي تتصدر مع الشعوب العالم الثالث ولها
صداقات قديمه السودان بالضروره بحوجه الى
الفيديو الروسي
تحت ظلال الخلافات الكبيره بين روسيا
والولدن والولايات المتحده
ليس لديها تاريخ لعب ادوار دبلوماسيه او
دوار الوساطه في السودان وهدفها الاول هو
الحصول على قاعده بحريه على البحر الاحمر
لمصالحها الاستراتيجيه
تعمل بمقتضى مصالحها الذاتيه روسيا الان
وطموحاتها تتصل
بصناعه دور متوازن وفرص متوازنه امام
السودان حتى يلعب الاستقرار
جميع الاطراف سوف
تصلوا الى مرحله تستفيد فيها من بناء
الدوله طبعا سوف تكون جزءا من هذا التحالف
الذي من شانها ان يساعد السودان بلد واعد
وفيه كثير من القرص الاستثمار المختلفه
وله موانئ على البحر الاحمر وله خيارات
كثيره في الزراعه وتبحث عنها فاقدر الذهب
هناك ايضا خطط لها علاقه بانابيب النفط
والغاز التي قد تمر الى البحر الاحمر ان
جميع القوى الخارجيه يهمها ومن اصلاحتها
ان يتوقف القتال وان ينتهي انعدام
الاستقرار لان هذا اذا لم يحصل قد يؤدي
الى مزيد من موجات الهجره المقلقه في
مصلحه احد ان يرى السودان تصبح دوله فاشله
واشنطن تتقاسم العديد من
المصالح لروسيا والصين في المنطقه ولكن ما
يثير قلق واشنطن كيف يمكن ان نحول السودان
الى حكومه ديمقراطيه
نظرت الى الامر السوداني باعتباره حاله
استثنائيه تتطلب جزء الوقت وجزم كثير من
الحكمه حتى تستصحب الراي العام السوداني
جميعه في عمليه سياسيه ترضي الجميع فهي
فسوف تقدم للسوداني الكثير من الخدمه
وتجلب الاستقرار في نهايه المطافه بمساعده
القوى الخارجيه بما فيها روسيا طبعا وفي
النهايه سيكون هناك تنسيق للجهود من اجل
ايجاد حكومه مستقره في السودان ربما قد لا
تكون ديمقراطيه ولكن هذا موضوع ايديولوجي
ما يهمه ان تكون الحكومه مستقره